now this is the way they posed it to you
and I have said before that sometimes
you don't just get a question you get a
method ascribed along with the question
I've never seen this particular method
prescribed in an edge of C before I've
seen a few of them I don't like this
method especially okay you'll see the
reason why it's not because particularly
law or anything I just feel and maybe
it's just because of the way my
particular brain works it's fraught with
error okay it's a little bit for me it's
a little bit like pouring you know a
kettle of boiling water with my wrong
hand I can do it but I'm kind of asked
to get burned like I'm sure I'm going to
spill it somewhere and it's gonna be
disaster for me so that is why I
consciously avoid this method but it
still worked
it's still accurate if you do it right
and some people use it that's fine okay
so let's have a go at this solve this
inequality with a table of values okay
now the first thing you have to do just
like the method that I suggested you can
do this graphically the first thing you
must always do is factorize because you
need to you can't read off features from
this thing there is no factorized but
that's not too hard this case right
you've got X minus 2 in the numerator
good okay fantastic
so now that I've identified this
factorized form I'm going to use it to
read features about this graft from its
factors okay
examples here there's a feature that X
minus 2 or the new red it tells me that
2 is an important feature of that
rational function ok um if it were a
polynomial the whole thing like a cubic
or a quadratic I'd call it a root but
it's a bit of a misnomer here because
the shape of these things - nothing like
a it's not gonna pass through the axis
neatly so a better way to call that is
okay because if I put 2 into this thing
the whole thing becomes 0 so it's called
0 ok now off the denominator I read
about two other features 0 and negative
3 now they're not zeros are they
it's it's zero now remember I'm trying
to stop thinking about this visually as
much as I can right because that's the
whole point of this approach of table of
values like I don't know what this looks
like so I'm not going to call them
asymptotes even if I drew y equals x
minus a lot it would be instead of that
but the more technical name that
corresponds to this is there
discontinuities they are discontinuities
now that's still kind of a visual word
but it's not as visual was asymptotes
what does that mean it means when you
put in these values the function breaks
right a continuous function is a nice
smooth curve and for any value of x that
you put into it you'll get a
corresponding Y value but if you put
these in you get nothing it just
explodes on you right so at those points
the graph breaks or the function breaks
there are gaps in them discontinuities
so these three numbers are important
features ok on either side of these
important features because I'm trying to
solve the inequality right on either
side of these speeches the sign of the
function changes from positive to
negative 1 it gets positive that makes
sense if you got a zero right it either
goes from like but the axis to above and
then it passes to zero or vice versa so
you're gonna have to change your side
okay so since these three are my
important values what I want to do is I
want to work out what happens in between
them so here's how I'm gonna start
filling in the regular value now what's
the order between 3 and 0 then 2 you'll
notice I have a whole bunch of gaps in
between them ok and I'm going to use
them to actually have values that I will
test on this actual function right
before I put those knives in before I
pick some numbers I'm just gonna do it
down I'm gonna write this for
discontinuity there
continually here and here the functions
equal to zero okay just for now dodge
the fact that there's no y this you guys
know what's going on that's the whole
function could it call it f of X s
question all right now I pick some value
I choose some values that lie in these
regions then I'm going to evaluate this
function on okay and I should choose
them to make things easy for me so I'm
gonna pick you know integers I'm gonna
pick ones that are relatively small if I
can so for instance here I'm gonna
choose negative 4 in between negative 3
& 0 what would you suggest negative 1
because 1 is the least complicated
number I can work with which means I'm
going to choose a bad as well and a
suggestion after 2 500 because you're if
you want to make big top of yourself put
it on astronomical odd number if you
don't choose a small number
all right so now I have these 1 2 3 4
values that I must test I want to know
what's this thing equal to at negative 4
and negative 1 and so on let's just
quickly do one of them you can see the
process and then I'll do the rest of us
already work them out okay so let's try
this one when x equals negative 4
okay so now I'm evaluating what's this
two equal to well on the numerator I've
got negative 6 and denominator I'm going
to have negative 4 times minus 4 per se
which is maybe okay so that's just for
right so what I got here what's my
actual value
negative 6 4 which is negative 3 2 okay
so that's my value and that's what I put
into here
now I'm gonna repeat that process for
all of these ok can you see by the way
what I'm doing here is what I tried to
do visually with you before when I did
the regions and I said look I've got 3
negative numbers over here so if you put
them together you'll get a negative I'm
not really interested in its magnitude I
just want to know if it's positive or
negative
all right and I have a negative okay now
just quickly because here's one I
prepared
oh yeah I'm worried about not what these
3 values are if I've done my numbers
right I should get think you can go
ahead and you can check that ok
pretty confident asides anyway what does
this mean you can see there's this
flipping around business right negative
positive negative positive which is what
you would expect of the function when
you saw what they look like you're gonna
be flipping sides every time right now
what I want to do is I want to see which
of these satisfies the inequality so
where am i less than or equal to 0 does
this check out is this less than or
equal to 0
yes it is so that's within the domain
that's good okay what about this oh it
doesn't because it doesn't exist okay
but it's important you note that because
that's gonna affect batteries that I
write in second three-on-two no good
just for new e no good negative 1/4 tick
it works zero it's inclusive aha all
right you can see when I actually put
these in cuz I want to check whether my
boundary will be a filled circle or a
hollow one and then what I 18 busted
okay so now I know the places that
satisfy the inequality now I can
actually write this thing okay so let's
look at me here you can see if I put in
negative 4 if I'm pretty negative 3 and
a half minutes really caught up in
cetera I'm still gonna be negative all
the way up until this point and then it
breaks okay so the ears are the the X in
the core the course wasn't that is
X is less than not including negative 3
that's what that's all I get from that
over here I'm okay
until negative 3 roll wrong ha
now it starts working again this part ok
right and this part ok so between here
and here right except for that boundary
between here and here I'm good so I can
say or 0 not inclusive because it's a
discontinuity remember X less than and I
can include 2 because it's a 0 right
it actually satisfies the inequality and
I'm done so that was the method you can
kind of see hopefully some of the
reasons why I dislike it
I'm even using this step here you just
get caught up in numbers which are
completely immaterial to answering the
question right I just want to know about
science of something about regions I
probably did you take a bit longer
because I was explaining it in a way
that other questions we've already
looked at grass before and you just look
above below done I also am NOT a huge
fan of like here you have to super
careful right whereas let's just quickly
compare okay I'm just gonna rewind in my
head back to this point ok once I have
this I can do this really quickly
alright let's go to 2 0 so I'm gonna go
1 2 I go through there
0 is an asymptote negative 1 2 3 is an
asymptote think about what this thing's
gonna be doing as X gets really large
your numerators gonna grow but the donor
is gonna take over you see that it's
quadratic it's gonna explode right so
I'm gonna have an asymptote of y equals
0 and then I can think okay I want to
have three negatives over on the left
hand side three negatives multiplied
divided any other combination will give
me a negative right so really quickly
region it's gonna swap
region region that's enough enjoy this
thing now watch one two three okay now
how do I know it does that partly
because I have seen these before fine
but just just logic it out for you so
have a look over here about what's going
on I have to be negative right I went
through the Regents processor that I did
before I just did it mentally okay I had
to be negative and I'm constrained
within these asymptotes where you gonna
go right you can't cross a vertical
asymptote so nothing's gonna happen over
here what about here you can't go over
the acetone because you must be negative
so you can't be in this region at all
you have a similar thing in here except
even worse right you're locked in this
region and you're between these these
kinds of bars right the lock you means
over here now this is a bit more
interesting I did not get to these
before but here's an example figure out
what happens down here must approach the
asymptotes
I must go through this and it's very
easy to see when you put in values like
100 a thousand million you're going to
come back down to zero so you cannot
just go up and then go off forever
he's got to come back down to the
asymptotes and when I teach you how to
differentiate when we do calculus right
you'll learn to identify those this
thing here called a stationary point
that makes it turn around and come back
to what the asymptotes none of that
matters for just answering the region's
question look I want greater inner core
sorry lesser than or equal to zero right
not inclusive to the left inclusive
sorry no yeah inclusive not in question
done you go okay so I really prefer this
method you can you can see where it
works you don't have to fuss around with
a large value in all these calculations
which I conveniently skipped for you but
we're taking some time to actually
working out